Donc, tous ces progrès récents incroyables de l’l.A. soulèvent vraiment la question :
« Jusqu’où cela va-t-il aller ? »
J’aime imaginer cette question
sous la forme d'un paysage abstrait constitué de tâches,
où l’altitude représente le degré de difficulté qu'a l'I.A.
à exécuter chaque tâche comme un être humain,
et le niveau de la mer, les capacités de l'I.A. aujourd’hui.
Son niveau monte en fonction des progrès de l’I.A.,
donc on peut voir une sorte de réchauffement climatique ici.
(Rires)
Evidemment, la première conclusion, c'est éviter les métiers en bord de mer,
parce qu'ils vont bientôt être automatisés.
Mais il y a une autre question bien plus importante :
« Jusqu’où l’eau va-t-elle monter ? »
Est-ce qu'elle va tout inonder
et être comparable à l'intelligence humaine partout ?
Voici la définition de l'Intelligence Artificielle Générale,
I.A.G.
le Saint Graal de la recherche en I.A. depuis son lancement.
Selon cette définition, ceux qui disent
« Il y aura toujours des métiers où l’homme fait mieux que la machine »,
disent simplement que nous n’aurons jamais d'I.A.G.
Bien sûr, on pourrait choisir de garder certains emplois humains,
ou offrir, par nos emplois, un revenu et une vocation,
mais l’I.A.G. va de toute façon modifier la vie telle que nous la connaissons
quand les humains ne seront plus les plus intelligents.
Maintenant, si le niveau de la mer atteint effectivement l’I.A.G.,
les progrès futurs de l’I.A. seront alors gérés principalement
non plus par les hommes, mais par l’I.A.,
ce qui pourrait impliquer de nouveaux progrès bien plus rapides
que les années de recherches nécessaires à l'homme pour aboutir.
Cela évoque la possibilité contestée d’un essor gigantesque de l’I.A.,
où l'I.A. qui s'auto-améliore récursivement
devance très vite l’intelligence humaine,
en créant ce qu’on appelle une « superintelligence ».
Bon, revenons à la réalité.
Allons-nous obtenir l'I.A.G. dans un futur proche ?
Des chercheurs célèbres en I.A., comme Rodney Brooks,
pensent que cela ne va pas arriver avant des centaines d’années.
Mais d’autres, comme Demis Hassabis, le fondateur de Google DeepMind,
sont plus optimistes et travaillent à ce qu'elle se produise beaucoup plus tôt.
Des enquêtes récentes ont montré que la plupart des chercheurs en I.A.
partagent l’optimisme de Demis, en fait,
et s’attendent à voir l'I.A.G. émerger d’ici quelques dizaines d'années,
donc du vivant de beaucoup d'entre nous ;
ce qui nous amène à nous demander « Et ensuite ? »
Quel rôle voulons-nous donner aux hommes
quand les machines pourront tout faire mieux que nous et moins cher ?
D'après moi, nous faisons face à un choix.
Première option, nous pouvons dire avec complaisance,
« Oh ! Fabriquons des machines qui font tout à notre place
sans nous soucier des conséquences.
Quoi ! Si nous créons une technologie qui rend l’humain obsolète,
que pourrait-il arriver ? »,
(Rires)
mais, je pense que ce serait inadapté.
Je pense que nous devrions être plus ambitieux, dans l’esprit de TED.
Imaginons un avenir de haute technologie, qui nous inspire vraiment,
et essayons d'y parvenir.
Ceci nous conduit à la deuxième partie de notre métaphore de fusée : le guidage.
Nous rendons l’I.A. plus performante
mais comment la guider vers un avenir
où elle contribue à la prospérité, non à la ruine des hommes ?
Pour aider dans ce sens, j’ai cofondé l'Institut « Future of Life »,
une petite ONG encourageant l'utilisation bénéfique de la technologie.
Notre but, c'est l'existence d'un avenir pour la vie
qui soit aussi enrichissant que possible.
Vous savez, j'aime la technologie.
C'est elle qui fait qu'aujourd'hui est mieux que l’Âge de pierre.
Et je suis optimiste, nous pouvons créer
un futur de haute-technologie vraiment exaltant,
si, et seulement si, nous gagnons la course à la sagesse,
la course entre le pouvoir grandissant de notre technologie
et la sagesse grandissante avec laquelle nous la gérons.
Mais pour cela, il va falloir un changement de stratégie,
car notre stratégie a toujours été de tirer des leçons de nos erreurs.
On a inventé le feu ; on s'est planté pas mal de fois ;
alors on a inventé l’extincteur.
(Rires)
On a inventé la voiture ; on s'est planté ;
on a créé le feu rouge, la ceinture de sécurité et l’airbag.
Mais avec des technologies plus puissantes comme l’arme nucléaire ou l'I.A.G.,
tirer parti des erreurs est une stratégie plutôt mauvaise, qu'en pensez-vous ?
(Rires)
Mieux vaut être proactif plutôt que réactif,
et planifier et réussir la première fois
car il se peut qu'il n'y ait pas de seconde fois.
C’est drôle, parfois les gens me disent
« Max, chuut ! Ne parle pas comme ça !
C'est de l'alarmisme luddiste. »
Mais ce n’est pas de l’alarmisme.
Au M.I.T., on appelle ça « l’ingénierie de la sécurité ».
Réfléchissez.
Avant de lancer sa mission Apollo 11,
la NASA a réfléchi à tout ce qui pourrait mal tourner
si on plaçait des gens sur des réservoirs d'essence explosifs
et on les envoyait là où personne ne peut les aider.
Beaucoup de choses pouvaient mal tourner ! Était-ce de l’alarmisme ?
Non, et c'est précisément cette ingénierie de la sécurité
qui a assuré le succès de la mission.
Et c’est précisément, à mon avis, la stratégie à adopter avec l'I.A.G. :
réfléchir à tout ce qui peut mal tourner pour s’assurer que tout se passe bien.
Donc dans cet esprit, nous avons organisé des conférences,
réuni d'éminents chercheurs et penseurs pour réfléchir à des façons de développer
cette sagesse nécessaire au maintien d'une I.A. bénéfique.
Notre dernière conférence, c'était l’an dernier, à Asilomar-Californie.
Elle a débouché sur une liste de 23 principes
qui ont reçu plus de mille signatures de chercheurs et industriels de l’I.A.
Laissez-moi vous expliquer trois de ces principes.
Le premier,
c'est éviter la course à l’armement et aux armes létales autonomes.
L'idée c'est que toute science peut être utilisée
soit pour aider les gens, soit pour leur nuire.
Par exemple, la biologie et la chimie ont plus de chances de servir
à inventer de nouveaux médicaments et traitements
que de nouvelles façons de tuer,
car les biologistes et les chimistes exercent une pression efficace
pour l'interdiction des armes biologiques et chimiques.
De même, la plupart des chercheurs en I.A.
veulent stigmatiser et proscrire les armes létales autonomes.
Le second principe issu d'Asilomar,
c'est atténuer les inégalités de revenus que l’I.A. entraîne.
Je pense que si nous pouvons générer des revenus fabuleux avec l’I.A.,
sans trouver de solution pour les répartir
afin d'améliorer la vie de chacun,
alors vraiment, c'est une honte pour nous !
(Applaudissements)
Bon, maintenant, levez la main ceux dont l’ordinateur est déjà tombé en panne.
(Rires)
Houah ! C'est beaucoup de mains levées !
Alors, le troisième principe va vous plaire.
C'est d'investir davantage dans la recherche sur la sécurité,
car si nous mettons l’I.A. à la tête de plus de décisions et d'infrastructures,
nous devons transformer les ordinateurs d'aujourd'hui, buggés et piratables,
en systèmes d’I.A. robustes et vraiment fiables.
Sinon, toute cette superbe technologie pourrait faillir et nous nuire,
ou être piratée et retournée contre nous.
Ce travail de sécurisation de l’I.A.
passe nécessairement par l’alignement de ses valeurs,
car la véritable menace de l'I.A.G. n’est pas la malveillance,
décrite dans les films bébêtes hollywoodien, mais la compétence.
C'est une I.A.G. qui réalise des objectifs ne concordant pas avec les nôtres.
Ainsi, quand nous avons provoqué l’extinction du rhino noir ouest-africain,
ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes un groupe malfaisant anti-rhino, non ?
Mais parce nous sommes plus intelligents et avons des buts différents des leurs.
Or l'I.A.G. est par définition plus intelligente que nous.
Donc, si nous ne voulons pas connaître le même sort que ces rhinos,
en créant l'I.A.G.,
nous devons découvrir le moyen d'obliger les machines à comprendre,
adopter et préserver nos objectifs.
Et au fait, les objectifs de qui ?
Et quels objectifs ?
Cela nous conduit à la troisième partie de notre métaphore :
la destination.
Nous rendons l’I.A. plus puissante,
en essayant de trouver un moyen de la guider,
mais où voulons-nous qu'elle nous emmène ?
C’est l'épine dans le pied dont presque personne ne parle,
pas même ici à TED,
parce que nous sommes obnubilés par les défis à court terme de l’I.A.
Ecoutez, notre espèce essaie de construire l’I.A.G.,
motivée par la curiosité et l'intérêt financier,
mais quelle sorte de société espérons-nous avoir si nous y parvenons ?
Nous avons fait un sondage récemment, et j'ai été surpris de voir
que la plupart des gens veulent la création d'une super intelligence,
d'une I.A. largement supérieure à nous sur tous les plans.
Et presque tous étaient d'accord que nous devrions être ambitieux
et essayer de répandre la vie dans l'univers.
Mais il y avait moins de consensus quant à qui ou quoi devrait être en charge,
et j'ai été plutôt amusé de constater
que quelques-uns voulaient que ce soit seulement les machines.
(Rires)
Il y avait aussi un désaccord total quant au rôle des hommes,
même au niveau le plus élémentaire.
Donc voyons un peu les futurs possibles
que nous pourrions choisir pour nous guider, d'accord ?
Comprenez bien que je ne parle pas de voyage dans l’espace,
mais simplement du voyage métaphorique de l’humanité vers le futur.
Donc l'option appréciée de certains de mes collègues en I.A.,
c'est de créer une super intelligence mais sous le contrôle des hommes,
comme un dieu réduit en esclavage, déconnectée de l’Internet,
et utilisée pour créer une technologie et une richesse inimaginables
au profit de quiconque la contrôle.
Mais Lord Acton nous a prévenus que le pouvoir corrompt,
et qu'un pouvoir absolu corrompt absolument.
Il est donc à craindre que les humains ne soient pas assez intelligents,
ou plutôt doués de sagesse suffisante pour gérer un tel pouvoir.
A côté des scrupules moraux que nous pourrions avoir
concernant l'asservissement d'esprits supérieurs,
il serait à craindre que cette superintelligence soit plus maline,
se libère et prenne le pouvoir.
J’ai aussi des collègues qui approuvent une prise de pouvoir de l'I.A.
même si cela mènerait à l’extinction des humains,
tant que nous estimons que les I.A. sont nos dignes descendants,
à l'instar de nos enfants.
Mais comment allons-nous savoir
que les I.A. ont adopté nos meilleures valeurs,
qu'elles ne sont pas des zombies sans conscience
nous attirant dans le piège de l'anthropomorphisme ?
Et ceux qui ne veulent pas l'extinction de l'homme,
n’ont-ils pas aussi leur mot à dire ?
Si vous n’avez aimé aucune de ces deux options haute-technologie,
rappelez-vous qu'opter pour une technologie bas de gamme
est un suicide du point de vue cosmique,
car si nous ne dépassons pas la technologie d'aujourd'hui,
la question n'est plus si l’humanité va être exterminée
mais comment elle va l'être par le prochain astéroïde meurtrier,
un super volcan,
ou tout autre problème qu’une technologie meilleure aurait pu résoudre.
Donc, pourquoi ne pas avoir le beurre et l’argent du beurre,
avec une I.A.G. non asservie qui nous traite bien
car ses valeurs épousent les nôtres ?
C'est en substance ce qu’Eliezer Yudkowsky a appelé « l’I.A. Amicale »,
et si nous pouvons fabriquer ça, ça pourrait être formidable.
Elle pourrait non seulement éliminer les mauvaises expériences
comme la maladie, la pauvreté, le crime et autres souffrances,
mais elle pourrait nous donner la liberté de choisir
parmi une variété nouvelle et fantastique d’expériences positives,
nous rendant, au fond, maîtres de notre propre destin.
Donc en résumé,
notre situation en matière de technologie est compliquée,
mais la vue d’ensemble est assez simple.
La majorité des chercheurs prévoit l'arrivée de l'I.A.G.
d'ici quelques décennies, et si nous plongeons la-dedans sans préparation,
ça pourrait être la pire des erreurs de toute l'Histoire de l’humanité.
Regardons les choses en face.
Elle rend possible une dictature brutale à l'échelle mondiale,
des inégalités, une surveillance et une souffrance sans précédents,
voire même l’extinction de l'espèce humaine.
Par contre, si nous manoeuvrons prudemment,
nous pourrions avoir un futur fantastique où tout le monde est mieux loti -
les pauvres plus riches et les riches plus riches -
et où tout le monde est bonne santé et libre de poursuivre ses rêves.
Mais, attendez !
Voulez-vous l'avenir politiquement de droite ou de gauche ?
Voulez-vous la société pieuse avec des règles morales strictes,
ou la société libertaire hédoniste comme un festival continu de Burning Man ?
Voulez-vous des belles plages, des forêts et des lacs ?
Ou préférez-vous réagencer leurs atomes dans des ordinateurs
et générer des expériences virtuelles ?
Avec l'I.A. Amicale, nous pourrions créer toutes ces sociétés
et offrir aux gens la liberté de choisir la leur,
car nous ne serions plus limités par notre intelligence
mais par les seules lois de la physique,
et donc, la quantité de ressources et d’espace serait astronomique.
Littéralement !
Donc, nous avons le choix :
nous pouvons être complaisant concernant notre futur
en prenant aveuglément pour article de foi
que toute nouvelle technologie est forcément bénéfique
et en nous répétant ça, encore et encore, comme un mantra,
tandis que nous glissons, comme un bateau à la dérive,
vers notre propre obsolescence ;
ou bien nous choisissons d'être ambitieux,
en réfléchissant à la façon de guider notre technologie
vers la destination désirée, pour créer l'âge de l'émerveillement.
Nous sommes tous ici pour célébrer l’âge de l’émerveillement,
et j’ai l'impression qu'au fond,
il consisterait à ne pas permettre à notre technologie de prendre le dessus
mais plutôt, à nous enrichir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)